another interesting thing about his name
he has a boss
named daniel robinson
who goes by the same nickname as him
and has the exact same name as his
identical brother
so a lot of name games going on over
there so everyone please welcome d-rob
thanks very much jared so i'm really
excited to be here to introduce the db
cooper package because we're turning any
database into an r package so this is
based on the observation that a lot of
um eda as currently set up in the nr is
built around reading data into memory so
it's like you import the data you
usually sign like read r then you do a
lot of then you
transform visualize work with the data
and a lot of like um of the examples and
our workflows are built around that but
the truth is that that's not usually
where data is a lot of organizations a
lot of um
of companies and governments not on
non-profits work with data in a database
so a shared source of data
and the um
and uh
it's really important when you're
working with that when your team is
going to be working with that every day
then working with a database should be
as easy for your team as possible
so the um so basically finding ways to
make r connect to the database really uh
really easily there's been a lot of
interest recently how do you build an r
package okay um
uh
my favorite talk in this is um is emily
readers talk from our studio conference
on how to make internal art packages a
part of your team
and um
i've been interested for a long time and
how do you build a package around a
database i particularly started first
started appreciating it when i was
working as a data scientist stack
overflow and um as the first data
scientists there created a package
called sql stack art
that wrapped their internal data
databases and i've done the same thing a
couple companies since i realized a
particular philosophy for turning a
database into a package that can be that
uh really anyone can apply
so excited to share the bb cooper
package uh which is available on on
github in the development version that
takes any database uh any database that
can be for your company it can be for an
also an open source can be for your
nonprofit and turn it into a database
specific package
so
uh
i'll talk a little bit about what
specific problem it's solving
think about what it's like to work with
a database uh
the kind of thing what kinds of things
do you want to do maybe you want to
start by like you want to list the
tables in a database see what's in there
maybe you want to use dply r to take one
of those tables uh transform it
transform it summarize it join it
collect it maybe you want to run sql
queries with r isn't enough you want to
execute commands like uh adding a table
or dropping a table that can't be done
within um deploy r
and um i'll give a couple of examples so
this is a really good package
um this is a really good example uh if
you want to play around with the
database
db player provides the lamin sequel
light function which in one step creates
a sequel light connection that contains
the lamin baseball uh data data set
those are data that i really like it has
um
and if i want to find out what tables on
it i would use dbi's db list tables to
see what tables are in this example the
uh
database so some of the things include
data on batting data on fielding on
pitching players salaries some team
specific data
and then all of this it's a really good
example if you want to try playing
around with the database and maybe i
want to take one of these tables and
look at it in deploy r to do that i
might do something like table uh then
the lamin database object and pass it
back if i want to look at the first
couple rows of the batting table
so here i've got one row for each um
uh where we one row for each player in
each year and i see a little bit i get a
little preview of this this uh batting
table in the database
or maybe i want to run a sql query so i
want to run like a grouped count and
then i can use kibble and that dbplayer
also provides a sql function for saying
i want to run this query against this
database and get back a table
and finally i might want to execute a
query against it so for that i would use
db execute i take that object i pass it
the command and it returns the status
so these are kind of the kind of four
examples of what you might want to do
with a database if you've worked with
databases you probably use syntax a lot
like this
a lot of the time you get your
connection you start doing things to it
you start getting it pulling out tables
running queries
now nothing's wrong with this approach
it's not that it's broken
it's that
something about using it has always felt
just a little bit off to me just a
little bit not like it's not designed
for the problem i'm really trying to do
and i thought a lot about this as i was
i was um starting at
working at companies and trying to work
with a database of thinking what it what
is it that's getting in the way between
me and the data that i want to explore
and work with
i've come to decide that i think it's
it's this it's so if i set up this this
database
it's really this object this lamin db
object that's a sqlite connection and
i'm not actually interested in the
connection object i'm interested in the
data i'm interested in taking actions
for the data like the functions i was
describing i'm interested in in the
tables the date actually reaching these
in for these nouns
the connection object doesn't really
enter into it and that for me is what
really feels off about it
so for me this missing puzzle piece
between ddi to create the connection and
dbplier to transform and uh and work
with these tables
so
that's what db
cooper enters db cougar turns the
database into a collection of functions
so you can intuitively work with it
it does that through a one-liner like
this the bbc init function so dbc init
takes that connection and then takes a
string that is a prefix for that for
that function so something that
describes it
what db cooper takes care of is it
stores and manages that connection
globally so in order to think about the
connection object and think about my
data then it generates some prefixed
functions for your task and autocomplete
friendly accessories for the tables
i'll show you what that looks like
we have these four operations we were
interested in listing cables accessing
one table querying and the end executing
and what dbc and knit does is it adds to
your name space four functions for doing
that it adds a lamin underscore list
which lists the tables in your database
log an underscore
tbl table for accessing one table to
work with it in d player
lam and query for running a sql query
getting the results to work within db
playard and lawman execute
send a notice is that something's not
present once you've done dbc init is
you're not working with the connection
anymore it's taking that story and
managing it globally while you get to
well get to use these functions to
access the data the database that you're
interested in
besides providing these functions i
think my favorite feature of it is
acting tables with autocomplete i find
it it's really a hassle to remember
what's the exact name of each of these
tables especially when they get really
long as often will in uh in a company's
data warehouse so it does is generate
one function for accessing each of these
tables so instead of doing quote batting
you can do alum and underscore batting
and i find that when i'm working with
data in exploratory way this makes it so
much faster to to kind of stay in the
flow of an analysis not think okay
what's the name of that table if i have
this this autocomplete tool that i would
if it were living in my environment
this gets especially helpful when you're
doing something like joins so in the old
old way you might say something like
table lam and db quote batting and every
single time you bring in a a new cable
you have to
use this function within the join and
also remember the name of that uh the
name of that table and that for me
always was taking me out of the flow of
an analysis it was feeling like these
table objects weren't something i could
really munch and work with and um and
transform and turning them into function
functions that i can autocomplete really
makes that kind of flow a lot um a lot
easier
so i'm going to show an example on a
less of a toy data set on the new york
times kova 19 database and this comes
from a big query set of public databases
so bigquery provides um public databases
for a
really large number of um open source
like uh
data sets and one of them you can work
with is new york times has every day
publishes a new database by count the
entire state of the united states covet
19 cases
and um
imagine we wanted to take that and wrap
it in something that let us work with it
and transform it so we would use
something like dvi to connect be cooper
isn't about connecting to the database
we're getting our database connection
using the big r query package
but the step we where we come in is
after creating that connection
you use dbc and nip on the connection to
create your library of functions
so once you've run dbc and to create
this library of functions
you could do covent underscore list find
out okay these are the four tables in
the data data set
and then uh
get user autocomplete covered u.s states
pick a preview of the u.s state's data
what's it from that it might be i think
about okay confirmed cases i'm not sure
what that uh what that means maybe you
want to look at just today's data so i
do a little bit of dpl transformation on
it i filter for the most recent data
that it has i arrange maybe descending
the number of confirmed cases i'm just
taking a look at these uh numbers and
check the docs to confirm it but based
on
a glance here these are cumulative
counts not on per day counts
so the um
so okay if i'm interested then and
transform this data another way i'll
need to like i'm going to calculate
those those regular accounts and i might
do something like this but i filter just
for new york and i look only at sundays
and i um calculate the the weekly cases
i say i said how many cases have they
been per week in new york turn it into a
bar club kind of bar we've all gotten a
little too familiar with this year of
something like cases per week
and so then i want to show here is that
that what baby cooper tried to do is get
completely out of the way of the fact
that you're working with remote data and
just turn that into one function covert
us states that now we can take it start
transforming it start working with start
thinking and reasoning about it
so it takes the connection object out of
the way let's work with it with the data
itself
so it's this is well the way that
whenever somebody gives me a database
and says what do you think the first
thing i'll do is run dbc init and i'll
explore it a little with but i mentioned
that the promise of this is really about
creating a package you can do for your
company or for your non-profit or for
your public data
for creating a package that wraps this
database
so so um i'll use an example this is
kind of going home for me is uh is in
fact i mentioned before that i first
used this kind of approach of writing a
database specific package when i was
working at stack overflow i don't work
with stack overflow anymore but there is
a public database hosted on bigquery of
stack overflow questions answers tags
and i imagine i wonder right and i want
to write a package that wraps that
database so anyone can answer the kinds
of questions they're interested in
so i actually do have this up as an
example of using db to create a package
it's on github as stack big query
and the um the way that i built it is
really three steps you always need to
have a little bit of logic that creates
the connection so it might use some some
kind of global authentication might use
some um
i might use some environment variables
and you're inter when you're writing the
package you're in charge of creating
that connection
but then what i do is uh in zzz.r which
is a conventional place and a package
for putting on functions that run on
loading and unloading i use this dot on
load
uh function
for it says when this package loads
create a connection
and then use dbc init to fill up the to
populate the name space of the package
with all the functions around this
database so it dynamically will create
all those packages and all those
functions and add it to the package as
soon as you load it
and then because we already have this
framework of the package i might add
some more database specific verbs so now
we've got our basics we've got our ways
to list tables into uh to access each
table individually but i might be
interested in some operations on this in
this case because stack overflow data i
might be interested in doing things like
aggregating by tags so i can count the
number of questions with a particular
tag or probing language and you can the
sky's really the limit here you add
functions to this skeleton that db
cooper gives you
and just like that you have a package
somebody wants to work with your um
with the the data they say library
stack bigquery and stack posts questions
we'll get them a preview of that for of
that table of the um the set of ques uh
questions stored in bigquery
so here we can see things like title and
the body of the question and the number
of answers that has the number of
comments it has and it's really um a lot
of
questions you can answer with this i'll
give one example um actually i have
uh just enough time that i can show
uh that i can show a little bit of like
a live demo we might do something like
say um
like say stack posts
questions and i might be interested in
um
let's say
finding something out per month i would
do something like date trunk of date of
um what is the creation date
by month
and it might somehow say what are the
number of questions
in each month
and by writing a an operation like this
it's actually turning into a query
running it and i want to learn a little
bit more i want advice about something
like average scores mean of score
and i might take that and put it into um
into a visualization where it says
something like month
average score how has the
and i might want to filter now that i'm
thinking about it for
only ones have more than similar some
solid number of questions turn it into a
line plot
and find out how the average number of
um of how the average score of a stack
overflow question has been changing over
time oh it looks like it's generally
been going down back in the good old
days of stack over they had high high
scored questions kind of been going down
over time
uh so the um
so this would be it would be how i'd go
about and answer the question with this
package and notice it all really comes
from like just this this one library and
then this one way to access the data as
if you had it as
a
variable right there in r
and you do more exciting things with it
i provide one example here of um
exploring tags over time we can see
things like the um the enormous growth
of the python uh tag but also both the r
tag and it's all based on on this
summarized tags function that i added to
the package and you can add a lot of
functions like that that really lets
someone explore your your um your data
in as rich a way as possible
so inclusion what i feel is really
important about db cooper and really any
kind of database package you design with
is you should underestimate the value of
small usability improvements that affect
you every day every single time you're
starting to go to your database what if
it were just that little bit easier to
start working with those tables joining
them together how much more productive
would that make you in the long term
on the other side of this i really do
think a good database package lets you
forget about the package completely i i
and
that earlier example i gave of covet 19
i want to point out that we're not just
working with the data anymore it
actually feels like you have the you
have these functions
and these these nouns these tables right
there in your uh environment and that's
kind of that's really i'd say the way
that that i recommend diving into any
database you have
thank you
thank you very much drob
always good to have
a drop talk
but even better to have a drop live
coding always a gutsy move and we'd love
to see it thank you drob that was
awesome